vous savez je vais peut-être vous
paraître ridicule mais je suis le genre
de personnes convaincues qu a pas de
hasard on écoute et on est moins bien
c'est que je suis sûr que ça marche des
conneries
j'ai cherché l'autre les dans ma chambre
de 12 à
elle est à toi
et hors ménage pas papiers mon bord de
la mer
tu es sûr que tu l'a jamais vu cette
chine ont remarqué que c'est un petit
peu plus pâlichon
qu'est ce qui va faire maintenant
l'accès est fermé jusqu'à chez lui tout
simplement
tu promets de sages ont pas faire de
caprice ou genre de truc ok ces points
pas légion c'est quelqu'un qui a besoin
de vacances
écoute il faut pas parler quand je suis
en voiture un tiens vaut le gamin là
vous le laissez tout en vivant comme ça
non des fois je devais dans le coffre ou
sur la galerie ça dépend heureusement
qu'un acompte sens des responsabilités
qu'est-ce que je devais 10,1 ne pas
bouger jusqu'à maintenant je me suis
toujours arrangé pour vivre ma petite
vie tranquille sans personne vraiment
merdé et l'ap
vous avez de la chance d'avoir un petit
garçon comme ça ça change une vie un
enfant
à gauche que les catastrophes de pictela
pas
et par contre l'histoire
tu vois bien j'étais dit